PC Remains the most varied customizable
and potentially powerful way to play so
as we wrap out 2022 it's time to look
ahead to next year and Beyond at the
bright future of PC games and go through
some of the most anticipated games
coming
about looks to be the first big RPG from
obsidian under the Xbox game studios
umbrella but all we know so far comes
from the short teaser trailer shown off
during the Xbox Showcase from July 2020
which revealed the game as a new first
person fantasy RPG set in the pillars of
Eternity universe
Resident Evil 4 was a medium defining
piece of work that influenced all that
came after it so marrying it with the
hugely successful style of the recent
re2 and re3 remakes has us pumped that
this remake might continue resident
Evil's domination as one of the best of
Gaming's horror franchises
many of us are excited for the follow-up
to respawns Dark Souls like Star Wars
Jedi Fallen order which many consider to
be the best Star Wars Story made since
Disney acquired the franchise Star Wars
and or notwithstanding continuing the
story of calcustus as he takes on the
Empire as well as his trauma left over
from the Clone Wars Survivor might be
the game to bring balance to the force
it's been a long while since we heard
from Bioshock Creator Ken Levine but he
finally unveiled his latest game with a
bang at the game awards 2022 like
Bioshock Judas is a narrative first
person shooter that takes place on a
disintegrating Starship and seems to be
about making or breaking alliances as
you try to escape we don't know much
more than that but we're certainly
excited given its pedigree
Hades too while we don't know much about
the much much anticipated sequel to the
seminal roguelike experience and one of
the best games of 2020 it's definitely
coming in early access in 2023 and
that's worthy enough of it jumping on
our list the game is supergiant's first
Sequel and it made a big pop when it had
its trailer released at the game awards
and it's certainly a sequel that brings
a lot of expectations that were really
not too worried that it'll be able to
meet
The Last of Us Part One a remake of one
of the best games on PlayStation is
making its way to the PC it arrives just
in time for anyone who might become a
new fan of the franchise as a result of
the upcoming HBO adaptation that we're
all excited for The Last of Us Part One
will be coming to PC on March 3rd 2023.
even if you're a fan of the original
game the Remake brings in a host of
great updates like more accessibility
options and some stunning graphical
upgrades that bring it up to par with
even the best of its more modern
competitors not to mention it still
provides one of the most heart-wrenching
and thought-provoking stories in gaming
picking up PlayStation exclusives making
their way to PC returnal will also be
looping back to the new platform
returnal was easily one of the most
surreal yet compelling action horror
experiences of 2021 and its unique
narrative helped elevate it to something
truly special that you don't want to
miss
Kerbal Space Program was memorable for
its complex physics that helped to show
a whole new generation how going into
space is actually extremely hard
countless kerbals have been lost in an
attempt to construct a perfect rocket
and the sequel looks to be even more
ambitious with a focus on Interstellar
travel you'll be able to cross galaxies
habitate planets make colonies and play
with fellow Kerbal enthusiasts in
multiplayer
while Activision Blizzard fans are
definitely wary of Diablo 4 given the
over monetization of 2022's Diablo
Immortal there is reason to be excited
for a proper follow-up to the franchise
as players take on the new villain
Lilith who is working to concentrate her
power Diablo 4 really feels like it's a
true hybrid of the best of Diablo 2 and
Diablo 3. from the Strategic healing
system to the more Dynamic Dodge ability
after a long wait Diablo 4 seems to be
everything fans have been hoping for
you'd be forgiven for forgetting that at
one point Perfect Dark was one of the
most well-known and respected names in
video games given that it's been mostly
ignored since its mediocre Xbox 360
launch title but this reboot developed
by the initiative alongside Crystal
Dynamics hopes to again prove that
Perfect Dark can be relevant to the new
more modern mature industry
despite us wanting it for forever all we
know about the Elder Scrolls 6 is that
it's real and it's being worked on we
got a short teaser trailer with a title
in 2018 and that's about it so here we
are patiently waiting maybe we'll get
another Skyrim to remaster for new gen
consoles and PC in the meantime
but speaking of Bethesda and RPGs one of
the most anticipated games right now is
Starfield bethesda's sci-fi space themed
take on these Studios RPG style Todd
Howard has certainly been ambitious with
this project with thousands of planets
promised in a detailed world there's
been a trickle of Dev Vlogs if you're
interested in the development of
factions Companions and major new
locations like new Atlantis neon and
Aquila and while fans are a bit wary
after Fallout 76 and even massive
Universe games like no man's sky at
launch we'll have to see if Starfield
will measure up when it releases in 2023
that's right a new Mass Effect is coming
and hopefully it's been calibrated just
perfectly announced that the game awards
2020 the upcoming entry in the fan
favorite series still seems to be early
in development with BioWare at the helm
while the franchise has a lot to prove
after Andromeda we're ready for BioWare
to prove why Mass Effect is our favorite
Space Opera on the Citadel the teaser
had nods to the Geth Liara and Reapers
but it's unclear which of Mass Effect
3's endings if any will become Canon to
tie into this new adventure
speaking of BioWare and Redemption
stories its other big franchise Dragon
Age is also ready for a Revival with
Dread Wolf coming off of Netflix
animated adaptation of the franchise not
much is known about this game other than
it being a sequel to the well-received
but anti-climactic Inquisition meaning
that like Mass Effect BioWare has to
bring its a game to this entry
forespoken looks to be a fun Twist on
the narrative driven RPG combining the
free-flowing traversal of Marvel
Spider-Man with a unique fantasy twist
with the main character being an average
girl from our world tossed into a world
filled with dragons and supernatural
abilities here's hoping that forespoken
manages to execute off its huge ambition
there is very little we know about the
new Fable right now but at least we know
it's real its reveal concluded the Xbox
showcase back in July 2020 and it was
confirmed that developer playground
games is behind the project it's
exciting to think about what Fable could
be in a new generation
one of a spat of games centered around
Supernatural multiplayer Heroes taking
on hordes of monsters red ball catches
our attention based heavily on the
Pedigree Arcane Studios the developer
behind Dishonored prey and death Loop
certainly knows how to make a game that
relishes in granting you superpowers so
having those skills put towards a
Cooperative game makes this one to watch
despite being delayed by the invasion of
Ukraine stalker 2 still plans to be an
ambitious step forward for the series
much like the rest of the franchise
stalker 2 takes place in the nuclear
exclusion zone or the Zone in radiated
Chernobyl but Supernatural elements lurk
about to create a horror-like atmosphere
it's said to have one of the biggest
open worlds ever in gaming which sounds
pretty daunting for the first person
action franchise but we're definitely
excited to see if they can deliver
senua Saga hellblade 2 continues the
harrowing journey of the titular
protagonist that started in hellblade
senua's sacrifice the first game was an
amazing exploration of mental health
using Norse mythology and we're excited
to see what Ninja Theory sequel can
bring with its expanded scope
Suicide Squad kill the Justice League
after the disappointing Gotham Knights
failed to reignite the dormant DC Comics
video game fandom Rocksteady is hoping
that it can bring it back with its
return to the Arkham Universe with a
take on the anti-hero troupe The Suicide
Squad while it's certainly not what we
expected from the house that Batman
built it might just be what the doctor
turned Harley Quinn themed super villain
ordered and with the announcement that
this game will feature Kevin Conroy's
last performance as the Batman it's sure
to tug at the Heartstrings
System Shock was a major inspiration for
later hits like Bioshock and after a
successful Kickstarter campaign night
dive Studios is bringing it back what
originally began as a remaster has
morphed into a full-on reboot however
sadly nightdive has run into development
troubles related to the pandemic and
other factors but the game is said to be
coming in 2022.
after proving its RPG medal with the
Divinity original sin games lyric in
studios is making a true and proper
sequel to the series that inspired it
baldus Gate 3 follows the events of
Shadows of aim and takes notes from both
the classic Baldur's Gate games and the
Divinity franchise An Early Access
version was released in 2020 and despite
some rough spots it showed a great deal
of promise and the full release it
slated for 2023
the World War II real-time strategy
series Company of Heroes is coming back
after a long Hiatus this time the game
will focus on the Italian and North
African theaters of war and includes new
features like a tactical pause that
allows you to queue up commands and
increase destructibility
despite some controversy over its lack
of diversity fans are still excited for
Final Fantasy 16. the next Mainline
entry in the famous franchise here
players will enter velicia a world
divided into three factions yet given
peace and prosperity thanks to the
mother crystals it looks to be an
interesting reintroduction to the Final
Fantasy franchise for new fans and
something that will make old fans
extremely excited
while fans are looking to the future of
Final Fantasy they will also be getting
a dose of the past as the follow-up to
the well-regarded Final Fantasy VII
remake comes out in the near future
giving us the next part of the story in
the seminal classic
despite seeming to have died years ago
Dead Island 2 was finally reanimated in
February 2022 with its Gamescom reveal
trailer leaving us excited that the
series can still take a bite out of its
competition Dying Light damn Buster
Studio seems to be well aware of the
expectations it has on its shoulders and
looks to bring an exciting open world LA
and San Francisco to its new combat
mechanics and rage systems like zombie
powers
atomic heart is a game that wears its
influences of Bioshock Metro stalker and
near automata on its sleeve and that's
not a bad thing the game a first person
shooter set in an alternate Soviet Union
1955 looks to be an exciting political
action game and we're ready for it
and that's our picks for the most
anticipated PC games coming in 2023 and
Beyond but despite our huge list we
almost certainly miss something that
you're